has anyone shared of time to be before
before we start just to give a sense of
the audience okay so you don't need to
there hopefully after this talk you're
gonna know everything about how to be so
Tagum is a system that we started inter
labs and MIT quite a while ago it seems
that we we spun it out into its own
startup but you know as to be respectful
towards the PI theta community community
we're gonna talk only about the open
source stuff today and everything you're
gonna hear in this presentation is open
source under the MIT license alright so
let's start with the problem something's
going on Derek okay so let's start with
the problem we will be focusing
exclusively on storage so although there
is a DB part inside DB this presentation
is gonna be about its storage aspect of
course we have a long been a very big
vision about tality again we are talking
about persistent storage of massive data
right and because of the fact that it's
massive we when we say persistent we
mean stored essentially on disk or on on
an object store on the cloud not in
memory the biggest problem that we
experienced while working on multiple
verticals is that there is a plethora of
different formats right before you store
the data you need to decide on the
format how are you going to store the
data and if you have worked on on a
vertical like genomics for example
you're gonna see tons of different
formats different specifications most of
them quite complicated then you go to
the lighter vertical you see something
completely different then you go to
databases and you hear proprietary
formats or park' or maybe some other
formats so there is indeed a lot of
different formats out there for storage
that you don't really just specify the
format we create actually a library or
some tool to parse this world right to
to essentially you know store the data
into the storage button and then
retrieve the data into main memory in
order to do computations so any new
library that is built around a format
has to implement one of actually all of
those aspects right the back-end support
for example is it's gonna work on s3 or
Azure or on the one on a distributed
file system you need to do some
efficient software development as well
for example you need to do to be able to
do parallel i/o because we're talking
about massive data you have to do
parallel compression and so many other
things so all these different formats
have to be associated with libraries
that can do over fancy-shmancy and one
of the facts that again
was extremely important for us is we can
debate about this offline later if you
like is that if you're doing some
efficient downstream computations you're
probably using some sophisticated
software like like a linear algebra
package and these kinds of packages
works directly on vectors or arrays
anyway right so regardless of the fact
that you may have a very creative format
that is very very compressed on the desk
at the end of the day you need to bring
the data into main memory lane it out
into some sort of vectors of or
multi-dimensional arrays and do the
computation on them using these packages
so to summarize this is perhaps the most
important thing to do now is that we see
two common problems so cross verticals
we see some redundant software
engineering because all these tools are
sharing some of the of the aspects that
need to be implemented and the second
thing is that there is a lot of
expensive conversion from whatever
format we had whatever data you're
storing into into our aims to do the
downstream computations so because of
that we are focusing on
multi-dimensional arrays to begin with
so these these are first-class citizens
in our world and imagination already
looks like this essentially it's a mac
dimensional object which is composed of
little squares called cells and they can
have different shapes and different
dimensionality this is the the simple
way to to to describe this now getting a
little bit more into detail about what
an array is let's focus on a
two-dimensional example we can have
dimensions like here for example you can
hear as many dimensions as you like the
dimensions have the dimensions can have
times right we'll give me integers or
you can behave it floats in some certain
applications and the
squares are the elements of the array
they're called cells and these are the
actual the actual objects that are
storing the values and you here you can
store as many values as you like for
example you can have as many fields as
you like of any of any type you want for
example here in this example which is
going to be running through the
presentation we have an integer
attribute industry measurement and all
the cells are responsible for storing an
integer industry so it's kind of
structured now also something extremely
important to emphasize on from the
beginning of this presentation is this
distinction we are making between dense
arrays and sparser and dense array has
all its it cells storing a value even if
it is an empty value for example if this
little cell you don't have anything to
store in it you need to store some Mal
body you need to specify something to
store it on the other hand if you have a
sparse array you are allowed to have
actually empty cells it's sparse arrays
usually occur when when the majority of
the cells are empty and we're going to
discuss more about this later so we have
dense in sparse arrays and the goals for
you know around storing and accessing
this data boil down to two things
Ascension slicing so you usually define
a multi-dimensional hyper rectangle and
you need all the data falling in that
rectangle and also compression because
again our data is massive now I'll give
you a couple of applications that give
me more of that for which we can model
the data as multi-dimensional arrays the
first one is lighter so this is this was
taken from a very cool project at NYU
that you should definitely check out so
like of data are essentially three
dimensional points in space in a beam or
new space that form surfaces okay
this one for example this is the city of
Dublin and these are essentially three
dimensional there's a three dimensional
space there is a lot of empty space
because you don't store a lighter point
for the air for example you store it
only for the surface of the objects and
obviously these are the non empty cells
in this domain so this is a huge three
dimensional sparse array now in image
for medical imaging for example where
you have x-rays and MRIs you can
represent or you should represent the
data as two-dimensional images so
sometimes it can be three-dimensional
for for MRIs for example in that case
the data is dense because these are
images you're actually storing pixel
values in the cells then epigenomics
this is another vertical where you get
massive data and it turns out that we
can discuss about this a little bit
later if you're interested this turns
out to be two-dimensional dataset
natural sparse so one axis you have
people you get the population on the
other axis you have the genomic
positions and this is a massive array
another application is time series which
you can think of I said you know the
data set is a bunch of vectors where
every vector is a time series for a
stock and you can of course always
collapse them into a matrix if you like
and finally even tabular data can be
represented as one dimensional array so
it is kind of a degenerate case it's a
batch of vectors one vector or graduate
now before proceeding I would like to
make another distinction between the
storage storage model and in the DBMS
and again again I would like us to avoid
the confusion of the time to be named in
this talk we're talking about storage so
let's explain what this means so the
storage module is responsible for stuff
like IO compression oxygen slice and
some API to higher-level application or
higher level modules and other filters
so it's very low level in other words a
DBMS on the other hand has a query
language the parser and optimizer and
executor and several other fancy things
in the Lady Elizabeth the storage module
has to appear in every DBMS like every
DBMS has some storage model however
again we would like to emphasize that
the storage module can be also
standalone you don't need to store all
your data in a DBMS and access the data
through an ODBC connector for example
you can use this storage module at least
this is the way we architect I'll DB you
can just use it as standalone and you
know you can use API from top to access
the data directly without having to go
so what is time to be poor for the
purposes of this presentation time to be
the storage module so this is the open
source part of it and trying to be
defines a normal map dimensional array
format so it's its specification it's a
format with the library and this is the
architecture like this is the way you
should think about time to be these are
the backends you can have cloud object
storage you can have distributed file
systems you can have even your your
laptop's file system trying to be
sitting on top it's a very thin layer on
top of storage it's a C++ library
because we're we're focusing a lot on
performance but at the same time we have
a lot of api's and we're going to talk
about the time from an RIT is a little
bit more expensive later and using these
api's we've been here integration to
spark and presto so that we can do some
more fancy things we're going to talk
about this as well now a few things
about the time to be historian I I used
to work for inter labs and MIT this is
where these project goals was conceived
in the beginning in 2016 we have the
first research prototype so we go there
talk to your database paper in in 2017
after some successes we have we span it
out of inter labs and MIT and we
incorporated in your company we have all
these nice people that you should
definitely connect afterwards a role
here there are magicians so make sure
that you talk to them and twenty
thousand eighteen and upwards were
hiring so if you come and talk to us if
you like our project ok so now I'm going
to get into there in three six of the
time to be format there is a lot of
documentation online so here because of
time constraints I'm going to touch on
all the most important features so that
you understand why were different from
other formats for example so this is a
two-dimensional example again again
suppose we have two attributes one is
integer one string and this is how we
lay out the data regardless of how many
dimensions you have at the end of the
day you have single dimensional files
right regardless of how big your spaces
you need you to map the
multi-dimensional cells into the one
dimensional space so this is what hardly
allow you to do through this tiling
approach that we have in the cell layout
again there is a lot of fear in it but
what you need to understand is that tile
DB allows you to map the
multi-dimensional space to an one
dimensional space in a way that you
retain the spatial properties of your
data and I'm gonna show you an example
maybe another important thing here is
that we split the attributes into
different plans that can be separately
compressed so essentially target is a
columnar format let me just put it this
way where I call them here is a magic
booted stop
it's only columns on one axis here right
so this is very important for for
performance so here you can see the
integer attribute at the top and then
the string attribute has two files
because it's variable length and this is
how we handle bearable length attributes
we're storing the offsets in a separate
file that is very highly compressible to
the beginning of each body and this
allows us to search on streets very very
fast now back to the spatial locality
suppose that we have this slices
admission with slicing query sub array
essentially you can see that with this
layout that we chose if you try to
identify wearing the files were we will
find these request itself you can see
that we have a good chance of finding
them continuously in the file this is
extremely important for performance
because we can do this kind of i/o
extremely fast so the key here is to
layout the data so that parallel i/o for
example or any kind of I all we do is
extremely fast because it is finding the
results close to each other in the files
they the sparse case is very very
similar the only difference is that in
this Park a s-- because we don't know
exactly where the non empty cells are we
don't store anything for empty values
this is important we're saving a lot of
space but we are we have to store the
actual indices the actual coordinates of
the non empty cells so this is truly the
only difference plus some very
lightweight indexing in main memory that
we do for this kind of arrays and you
get a unified view and unify the API and
so on so forth for both tennyson sparse
arrays on this this
how this looks like every array is a
folder it is truly a folder it's not a
huge blob do you have some make up data
files and then for every write that we
do we have a sub a timestamp subfolder
and when I get to that in the next slide
so imagine that that the data falls into
this timestamp supplement for this parse
case it's exactly the same but there is
a coordinates file and some more
indexing metadata over here in the
fragment metadata file and that's it
this particular format allows us to do
very fast update and with some other
perks for example for tolerance so let
me explain how this works our updates
are matched so you'd better accumulate a
lot of updates they flash
rather than doing set myself this is not
very wise you can do it but this is
going to be relatively slower so suppose
that we initially load this into this
creates a time stamped subdirectory as
you can see on the right there suppose
that you want to update only this corner
so if you style for example this becomes
a different subfolder so all files in
our world are immutable we never do
update engine in place and finally in
the dense array you can even do sparse
updates this is treated as a separate
snapshot of a sparse array and this
becomes a third subfolder so this is the
main idea of course the user just sees
the actual the final snapshot it's like
super imposing every update called the
fragment on top of each other to get
this logical view and our real algorithm
is very very efficient but very very
sophisticated to touch as little
redundant information as possible across
all those folders and in addition to
that because this looks a lot like the
log straight structured merge trees
approach we have a very nice
consolidation algorithm if for example
you're numb the number of your folders
is getting out of hand we can purge very
very efficiently into one directory but
essentially has this view
okay a few more nice features in tile GB
we are all about performance so we have
a very nice feature about filters that
is coming up in the version 1.4 and this
is gonna happen in a couple of days so
remember the data along one attribute is
a file right in one fragment so suppose
that this is a binary file now the
concept of tile is useful because this
is the atomic unit of i/o and it is
essentially a collection of values
contiguous in the file so this is the
tile and what we do is that we shank the
tile even further in pieces that can fit
in l1 cache this is extremely important
for performance and then we run each
chunk into a filter pipeline that the
user might might have defined and we do
everything in power so this is extremely
efficient in ontology B we have the
collection of filters of course we do a
lot of different compression algorithms
we have items' pizza for encryption
Delta encoding bit with rate reduction
in this this is a growing list now
another extremely important thing about
tile DB is that it works beautifully
beautifully currently on s3 and soon on
Azure Google Cloud and Alibaba cloud
because this is because of their format
like this is an artifact of of the
format for example if you have a code
that works pretty pretty well on your
laptop and then you just change the name
of the array from my array to an s3 you
Arai everything is just gonna work as
efficiently right this is this is a big
thing you don't need to change to
another library you don't need to set up
a service the code just works the second
thing is that although there is no
concept of directories or next really
there the slash character in the path
has a very natural intuitive minute
right it's a hierarchical
path so this works beautifully for us
and it works beautifully because we can
run this command from there from the
command line interface of s3 and say ok
we're gonna sink a local directory to
the cloud in a bucket so for example an
array directory to the cloud then if you
start querying the cloud it's everything
is just gonna work
advice versa if you said created an
array on a string and you sink it down
to to a folder locally your code is just
what I work by changing the URI and as I
mentioned of course we're adding more
buckets now in terms of parallelism once
again I mentioned that tydides Beebe
performance so it's fully multi-threaded
right using Intel TBB try to be does not
rely on an external library for
parallelism does it does everything in
the code we of course have we're very
serious about thread and process safety
there is no need for locking because of
the way we create immutable objects
there is no way to hear faults we are
for call around in that respect there's
no issue of corruption and we have a
multiple read there multiple writer
model this is very different from out
from other formats we of course we're
very leaving in peril I know as well we
do a lot of optimizations for s3 for
example we're using the s3 multi-part
upload a lot we use by drains requests
in parallel so we do a lot of fancy
things there with the parallel filters
parallel sorting parallel slicing so
everything inside the B's part in terms
of api's as I mentioned that DB C C++
library it exposes the C API
we're building a C++ API on top of the C
API and we have a Python Argo and Java
API as well
so we are extremely big in in terms of
integration we we already started work
on both spark and presto essentially you
can hear spark dataframes and you can do
sequel queries using presto through that
own tile VB data because we created the
appropriate connectors the presto
connector is going to be open source
very very soon and we are extremely
again careful about creating these API
interfaces in a very like with matter
for example when you're slicing a time
to be array into an amp I array we do
some very careful work there for example
we allocate the Napa array in the title
world then we take the C pointer of the
numpy array and this is what we're
pushing in totality and thank
performance is zero hoping you're not
hiring so it's not a trivial integration
we get very deep into the details of
this API we can predict a true star we
do a lot of stuff around the spark and
presto and we do a lot of partitioning
because these this software is parallel
in a multi processing way so we help the
software achieve performance on time
together so I'm going to essentially
finish with a little comparison for
those that are familiar with other
formats for example HD vine is very
popular czar also in the Bible world in
pack n so let me let me mention a couple
of things so first of all time to be HD
HD v ends are our formats for
multi-dimensional rates but no parking
but here there is no notion of
multi-dimensional arrays title is the
only format that can perform natively on
they can support natively in sparse
arrays pretty much all they all the
format's are doing compressions in
theaters or everybody's good there in
terms of parallelism time to be pushes
all the parallelism down to tile be the
don't depend on another layer on top of
that the other assistance group and for
examples are uses parallel compression
through loss but they need to realize
that or for the rest of the stuff and
the same goes for parallel i/o we do
everything in in our code we have
multiple writers multiple readers
versus single writer multiple readers on
HD Fi and the rest are pushing pushing
these up to the applications in terms of
updates because of these of this design
were extremely fast on the cloud
whereas for for the rest of the formats
you need to change a bigger chunk of
thing in our case you just change what
you actually change this is the only
thing that you write the other formats
have to take a bigger piece like a chunk
or a file in code for extra support note
that everything is open source in our
world it's a fight to the best of our
knowledge this isn't the Enterprise
Edition outside of course is open source
it for for parkade if this just pushed
you to a higher level and finally in
terms of api's we want to integrate with
the with the wider
of course Michael makes one of our most
popular api's part you know Alex exactly
a close second for example and also we
have Java whereas the rest are pretty
good in that respect sorry is a
beautiful project but it works only in
Python by the way just to let you know
we said the choice of these parameters
was not intentional just happen to them
for us to be very very good all right a
very small comment around a No
I'm pretty sure there are people here
that are fans of our week we are fans of
ro as well this is an in memory corner
for all right this is the in memory on a
wall for parking isn't it speaker
resistance for arrow is delegated either
to parquet for example or you can
achieve it through meme' Italia means of
course more and more flexible around
that and the reason integration with
parquet coming up so please stay tuned
if you're interested with this I'm going
to close a presentation this is the
first time we participate in the PI data
community we have been very meticulous
in order to come up with and with a
great project to share with you and not
we're in a good stage to do so so if
you're interested in both sparse to
dance arrays
thank you what hit resistance and you
want integration with the wider
ecosystem and you are very big in
performance and you're very big in
integrating integrating with multiple
pockets perhaps you should just take a
look at Sally
so with that thank you very much of my
part if I have not made it clear that
we're hiring and I would like to you to
let Jake for for at least a few minutes
show you a couple of cool stuff we can
do with time yeah
so I'm going to show off some work that
we've done with our team members Tyler
and Seth so the first project that we
did in the spring was with the Naval
Postgraduate School and it was just
exploring like we had this sparse array
of data storage manager what does that
look like for lighter data and lidar
data is actually stored as a record
format so it's not in a kilometer format
so this is just a kind of
proof-of-concept work that we did with
them and so basically we took data from
this project which is basically a
high-def laser scan of Dublin city and
as you can see this is just to get you a
taste of what a view looks like through
Python you know an import panda is
titled be numpy we basically load the
pre ingested how to be an array this is
from local so our file system and you
can see our domain here it's pretty
simple right XY and z coordinates in
some projected common coordinate space
the poppy cursor and so what people
don't know about is the latter format is
actually very rich so you have XY and Z
but also if you're doing GIS stuff right
you have all these other attributes that
are collected for every single lidar
point and so most of these are not using
your analysis right so you want to do a
some type of projection from the
database community or basically just say
I want to focus on XY and Z and I want
to ignore intensity returns flags all
this other stuff write it in my analysis
and the problem with the lighter format
since its record based you have to
basically skip over those parts of the
file you know in memory so you lose your
memory locality in that space so we
basically reorganized it into attributes
so for every x y&z point we have an
attribute with different data types
using different compressors because some
compressors work better for some types
of data than others and so here we're
just grabbing the data and you can see
that the coordinates are just you know
stored as a record in tile disease or
storage record
and they've just in an umpire a format
directly and we can basically extract
out the x y&z and we're here just going
to show you like basically a small
subset of the data as you can see here
some just raw light our points it's kind
of hard to see which is two raw points
but you can kind of make out buildings
and streets and stuff and if we go down
here
each each point is further classified
basically by whether it's vegetation or
whether its ground so we can extract out
those points and then basically color
the result object based on the lidar
classification and as you can see here
like we do some decimation you can see
the buildings a lot more better that's
just to highlight the buildings but you
can see like a park over here because
that's a lot of vegetation so it's just
showing you that you know we didn't do
anything special with tile DB this is
taking a generic lidar format
reinvesting into tile DB and you can do
all sorts of the analysis that you're
used to on lidar data so this is another
just basically simple demo which is
showing you as s3 integration so this is
pre ingested data that's financial data
on s3 and so we're here just basically
this is basically the fragment layout
that stavros described before and we're
gonna load the data and we're gonna see
here that this is our dimensions that
were that we set up and this is when you
think about it like a multi-dimensional
index on top of a traditional database
table right ordered in time and so here
are the attributes so you have a bunch
of different attributes and a common
analysis that you want to do again is a
projection right you want to only focus
on subsets of attributes on some range
queries sub query in time so one thing
that Seth R has been working on a lot
and from our team is working on Presto
integration so what's cool is that you
know we could take our common format and
we can
just natively hook it up to a decoupled
database like presto and now you can
perform SQL queries on your Aradia sets
that way up way up here we just read it
directly into numpy Python but you can
do the same type of operations exactly
the same type of operations it's equal
and so here's a trick you know like a
traditional array query where we're
sitting on bid sized bid price sized
offer price offer size over all dates
for these times and for these sequence
IDs so a traditional like numpy array
slicing syntax right so this is a
traditional array query that you want to
do it takes a little bit of time because
this is about you know I don't forget
how many gigabytes of data but you can
perform the exact same analog in sequel
write and do a native query with presto
and so this is basically showing like we
do our projections or selecting on some
sets of attributes or dimensions from
this pre ingested data set and this is
our basically our range query and we're
just limiting the print there's no push
down for presto for four limits but
we're just limiting it to only prints
out a little bit of results so it just
shows that you can you know natively
there's no reason to have all your data
locked up into a database system if you
do batch updates that type of storage of
data you can upload to s3 and work on it
with weather tooling your cookie you're
comfortable with or whatever tooling
salts your problem right you can do SQL
for maybe ETL or just you know maybe
some people in your team are more
familiar with it or you can do direct
analysis load into an umpire raise work
on it and pandas do some fancier type of
analysis that that would be very
difficult to do in SQL all in the same
format all in the same system pretty
seamlessly so that's the goal that we're
trying to push for in the future so
that's my spiel and
I think we're ready for questions anyone
have any questions
can you describe your type system yeah
so our type system is is pretty simple
right now on it's mostly just your
common scalar formats that are available
in numpy and we also have variable
arbitrary variable length data types so
data types that you would need to store
almost all sequel values except daytime
so date/time is a big one we're working
on now and we have string support but
hierarchical objects that arrows would
support like sets or nested JSON arrays
it you know that type of data type we
don't support yet but we can serialize
into an arbitrary box so the format is
agnostic it's just you know it stores
bytes it can be fixed sized or variable
size and everything works on that
abstraction so plugging in a more
efficient type system is a to do and you
know like more expressive types and we
can build on top of that there's nothing
there's it's the system's already we're
rewriting it so that that that's just an
extension in the future that we can
continue add but yeah some of these
types are very important especially if
you want to share between systems right
yeah that the common type tag
representation to make sure that you do
the conversion correctly anyone else I
need any other questions
from the Python API point of view if you
slice or select some part of an array
and it's stored as spaz on the far end
do you get a space object out or do you
just get an umpire a so that's a good
question since ours since we want to
work with multi-dimensional sparse
arrays right because we want to support
arbitrary dimensions Python only doesn't
have very good support for that there's
there's currently projects in the
community to support and dimensional
sparse objects so we basically store our
memory representation you think of as a
coordinate format right we're a
coordinate formats for sparse arrays so
yes it's very easy to take our
coordinate format and then convert it
into a sigh high sparse array but we
don't do that for you because it doesn't
right it only would work for two
dimensions so it doesn't it doesn't
generalize very well but it's very easy
to do anyone else have any other
questions like we talked I really
enjoyed it
um how expensive would it be to
re-implement how DB and something likes
JavaScript I asked this question because
of hdf we had this problem there was
really just one implementation and all
of our data is tied to one groups code
yep so what's how hard are we to replace
you so the format itself would be very
easy to replace because the format is is
designed to be simple because we want
you're like if you have an open spec
format you want it to be simple right so
that would be pushed to the read
algorithm and you could reimplemented
that in JavaScript I think the only
blocker that we would have is if you
wanted compression there's very limited
compression options available to my
knowledge I'm not a JavaScript
programmer I'm available for JavaScript
natively so I don't know what the
support in javascript is to say like
cross-compile
c STD into web assembly and then run
that or how big it would be or if
anybody makes sense so I'm very
confident that we could create the
project to natively read tile DB arrays
and
the script without compression without
the full suite of compressors that we
support basically so we haven't tried
that yet but it would be an interesting
project to see if we could like rip out
well all our compressors are modular so
if we ripped all that out and just had
you know simple serialization what we
probably could cross-compile I would
imagine at this point because it's you
know if you turn off threading to that's
also optional so yeah I'm pretty sure as
long as you can cross compile C++ code
now to JavaScript it seems like it's
getting pretty sophisticated we could do
it just compressions an issue so that
would be something and we would have to
talk about more like with a JavaScript I
swear I think does anyone else have any
questions we have five minutes any other
questions
can you talk a little more about the
parallelism especially on there on the
reading so if I'm reading larger right
so there's two so it's as well just use
s3 is for example because that leverage
is the most amount of parallelism right
so is that's free you get scalable I
mean it works amazingly well you get
really scalable i/o with a number of
thread issue requests right up to some
size from node size based on the
bandwidth of the ec2 note to the s3
object store so you want to spin up on
large notes large number of threats so
we have a background we basically
abstracted part of our i/o component and
that's called our virtual file system or
you know VFS layer and that has its
nolan internal thread pool so now that
dispatches you know say 20 threads and
they are doing multi-part get requests
from an s3 object right that brings them
into buffers in a tile to be now
depending on if it's a dense array or
sparse array so as far sir a you would
have to maybe have to resort or do you
can pull up first you have to run the
filter pipeline backwards right so you
have to you know decrypt uncompress and
all that's done per chunk so the work is
divided up into small bits and run you
know basically in in cache across all
processes on your thread using the load
balancing available through until TBB
runtime so we get massive parallelism on
that side
- so basically it's scale since you know
compressions a big big big cost it
scales to the number of course that you
have it very efficiently uses the number
of core are the number of threads and
one recourse available and then that's
copied back into your buffer after it's
decompressed so parallel sorting is for
for sparse right so you have a bunch of
updates that might intersect with each
other so you have to compute the
intersection of coordinates and then
basically duplicate the coordinates and
then take the coordinates that we're
last written and so all that algorithm
has been rewritten and so it's fully
paralyzed
um and then that was a lot of work so
kudos to Tyler pulling that off but yeah
it's we basically rely on Intel a lot of
the Intel TBB runtime a lot because it
does a very very good job of low
balancing you know two separate tasks
and basically work stealing so yeah any
other questions we have two minutes for
any questions anyone else have any
questions no all right well please go
wrong applause birch
[Applause]